what's the worst thing you've been  called  me  um  i don't think it was a word i saw a  comment  i was talking about like my acne was  really bad when i was doing drugs  and i was like  drinking more water to get my skin back  right you know like  everyone do the same  and and i saw a comment said you'll be  dead by august  this was like two years ago so haha  you know how they are  for sure sir  now we're now we're in september this  year yeah so [ __ ] you do the math yeah  count the days i won you won that yeah  but it said you'll be dead by august and  that i was like okay  wait i know i know it's it's like maybe  like a fan reaching to like try and get  my attention or some [ __ ] yeah that that  was but that bumped you out that was  sharp no during august were you extra  careful  i don't know i think i forgot